foreign  comes out of giving an audience  information you see so many films they  call them mystery films I never make  mystery films because no we know because  if the audience don't know  how can they emote  it's like a whodunit I never made who  done it because you're gonna turn the  last page before you find out anything  so who done it in from an audience point  of view is an intellectual exercise like  a crossword puzzle or an anagram  you're wondering which of the five  people  so there's no emotion it's just  calculation  but suspense is very different  you tell the audience  that there's a bomb under that chair  and we'll go off in five minutes  I'll make them wait  that's right